NARRATOR: Gotham City,
a cauldron of crime
and corruption
about to boil over.
BATMAN:
I'm trying to save the city.
CATWOMAN: So am I.
I just get paid for it
better than you do.
NARRATOR:
A new nightmare whispers
from the edges of sanity.
SCARECROW:
This is the Scarecrow.
I'm in your head!
Don't you remember?
You're fighting me.
NARRATOR:
A criminal mastermind makes
a play for total control.
JOKER:
There is a terrible corruption
at the heart of the Gotham City
Police Department,
and it goes by the name Batman.
NARRATOR: And an agent of chaos
makes her deadly debut.
HARLEY QUINN:
I'm Harleen Quinzel.
I think I used to be a doctor?
NARRATOR: Hang on
to your headphones
and tune in for ten
all-new explosive episodes.
Stream every episode of DC's
Batman: The Audio Adventures
season two on HBO Max
starting October 7th.
And don't miss the seven-issue
Batman: The Audio Adventures
comic book series
by the writer
of the award winning
Batman: The Audio Adventures
podcast.
Get it a comic shop near you.
Or read it digitally
with a subscription
to DC Universe Infinite,
dcuniverseinfinite.com.